you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with a mental health problem
also known as a psychiatric disorder
this video will help you understand how
the brain works in mental health and how
problems can cause mental illness
mental health is your ability to handle
or cope with stress and enjoy daily life
it includes the way you feel think act
and relate to others
scientists study how certain brain areas
affect mental health for example the
fear area of the brain called the
amygdala helps you avoid harmful things
and escape danger in addition the
amygdala works with the prefrontal
cortex to control your response to
fearful and stressful events the
prefrontal cortex also helps you make
decisions solve problems and recall
memories the anterior cingulate cortex
helps you focus on tasks and control
emotions
the hippocampus helps make and store new
memories
the working units of the brain are cells
called neurons also known as brain cells
neurons pass messages to each other
through electrical impulses the impulses
pass along a part of the neuron called
the axon
here's a closer look at how a message
passes from one neuron to another at the
end of the axon the impulse causes the
neuron to release chemical messengers
called neurotransmitters these chemical
messengers move across a tiny space
called a synaptic gap and attach to
another neuron this triggers the neuron
to produce its own impulse
in this way impulses spread across the
brain problems with this process may
result in brain disorders known as
mental illnesses all the causes of
mental illness aren't known however a
number of factors may contribute to it
some of these factors are a family
history of mental illness which can be
passed from parent to child through
genes severe emotional or stressful life
events or a head or brain injury other
factors may include health problems such
as heart disease
problems with other chemicals in the
body called hormones
drug abuse and addiction
and an imbalance of chemical messengers
in the brain
when there is an imbalance of chemical
messengers in the brain neurons may have
trouble passing messages between each
other
the most common chemical messenger is
glutamate it increases the chance that
an impulse will form in other neurons
people with mental illnesses such as
autism obsessive-compulsive disorder
schizophrenia Alzheimer's disease and
depression may have problems making or
using glutamate serotonin another
chemical messenger helps control mood
hunger and sleep for example people with
depression often don't have enough
serotonin dopamine helps control
movement and is involved with feelings
of pleasure and addiction
low dopamine levels or problems with the
brain's ability to use it may be linked
to schizophrenia attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder or ADHD and other
disorders
an estimated forty 3.7 million adults in
the United States have some type of
mental illness
modern research tools and advanced
technology will allow scientists to
better understand the brain and how
mental illness occurs
if you have questions about mental
health or any medications you have been
prescribed speak with your health care
professional or doctor it is important
to take your medications as directed by
your health care professional or doctor
tell them about any side effects you
experience